we make collectively almost 9 $95,000 a
year and um at this point how much are
well like what's your margin going to
the debt snowball every
month we can maybe put an extra 150 he's
working two jobs I'm working jobs did
you 15 what dollars no
girl
95,000 yeah you shouldn't have told me
that that's that's not intense that's
not intense at all
well no wonder you're worried about
these $20,000 balances because that's
going to take forever you got $95,000
coming in that is not all going to
$10,000 worth of debt that your parents
took out in your name where the flip is
all your money
going uh my car payments and other how
much is your car payment uh mine's $700
okay what's the other car payment his is
950 sell the stupid cars today